hello guys this is key from SHINee today
I'm gonna be talking about my first
times first kpop song k-pop Iran body
band rose you would have a dream where
their Chi on the way I see it I'm your
girl
Yamaha - I think first thing you do when
you wake up I checked my cell phone
first and drink a glass of water I take
a shower if I don't have a schedule I
don't take a shower first nickname punky
yes sir
your days are tabletop she gonna do
Instagram I'd you go home security
Seneca good day to me only a Casa Bonita
village or credo mobile singers first
performance on stage it was 11 years ago
May 25th and I looked really ugly first
impression of America Americans are
generous for lots of cultures humble
water time and in ándara
oh they're generous for a lot of
different cultures first true friend
what you going to change now go Tokyo
young and Dave Tom chin-hua chin-hua
sumo champion gives on yourself totally
first embarrassing moment on stage it
was eight years ago
long story short my zipper wasn't close
enough and I was wearing red underwear
first time realizing you were famous
Park and out there loboslewd avatar was
majestic
each empire Norris when you get in there
heavy algo para hearty with an aggressor
I knew that I was famous first storm
apartment with your bandmates
it was disaster and hell on John truble
f1 coming into the garage come true when
there's also cool Tanya [ __ ] higher cool
DJ Taro's hollandaise chicken like best
friend ever
you don't know
[Laughter]
someone yeah k 1y l k1 it wasn't a k1
when we used to live together
it was k1 this is so embarrassing first
a livery crush boa since when I was 14 I
love her music and I love her style and
all of her personality identity
everything she's my real idol and she's
my role model I think no she is first
big purchase
I bought a car six years ago meaning to
say come cha GI arrayed on untie us in
the day cuz it's homo chariot bunny sin
20 more
surely no my father bought a car for me
girls just went awry careful EMW
yesterday it was three years ago
honey Antoine come back to her first
time you ever cooked so 20 years ago I
made a mashed potato for my grandma
sounds so sweet
Josh she of citta what it wasn't good no
I'm a magic about your first kiss really
no first pad kokorin encouraged on the
day sir cosmos our tango Chickoo Chickoo
moon Condor Ankara's american Hippolyta
[Music]